I'm going to attempt to stream a little
bit of dev today.
My uh laptop has not been behaving at
all lately.
No idea what's wrong with it. Some
drivers or whatever. So, if things are
super crashy, we'll just I'll just do
stuff off stream. But uh I figured it
would be fun to at least try to do some
drone stuff today.
I kind of did this experiment and forgot
about it. Let me see if it did anything.
Not really.
H
I put a bigger model together just to
see if a bigger model would do anything.
And yeah, it doesn't really seem to do
very much. It's like a little better,
but not really.
Oh yeah, I have the chat off here. Let
me fix that.
There we are. Now things show up there.
So, uh, the crazy thing that's happened
in the last day is the extent to which
this article blew up. This was really
cool to see.
I mean, I've been just reading through
all the different messages on this It's
been uh it's been pretty cool. I mean,
this one has
318,000 views on it.
I wasn't even going to write this one
honestly cuz I was like, "Yeah, okay,
whatever. Do I really need to do a
general programming in ML thing, but
like it is kind of the core bread and
butter of everything I do." So, I
figured that it would be useful for
people and apparently folks agreed.
Welcome.
We
we
welcome.
Why Why is the algorithm like this?
All right. So, we are going to actually
do a little bit of real work today.
Just a little bit of real work.
Wrong terminal.
and we're going to hope that uh machine
is stable today.
I don't know how we got to a point where
I cannot like I can't get a new laptop
that actually works, but
here we are.
I forgot if I had a building.
Looks like it.
Morning, Magic. What are we doing today?
We're working on a uh like an all-in-one
drone simulator that's going to be able
to do a whole bunch of different tasks
uh on different types of drones with the
same policy.
And it's going to be fast enough that
you can run the policy on like an
Arduino or a toaster if you want.
Maybe not an Arduino to be fair. You
probably need like
those are really really slow, right?
Arduino might be slower than some smart
toasters. I don't know.
Read the RL article yesterday was pretty
good. Thank you. There's a lot of um
really a lot of my best advice is in
there. It's like the language in that
article is very simple, a lot of it, but
if you actually look line by line,
you'll find that there's quite a bit of
uh information densely packed.
Welcome, chicken.
I suppose we are we are probably going
to have uh some new people from X today
because of the article. So, uh, yeah, I
guess I didn't mention that in any of
the articles, but I stream all my dev,
pretty much all my dev.
Sometimes it's like fast-paced and we're
doing really cool stuff. Sometimes I'm
kind of just hanging out and thinking
about what I want to build next and
such. But, uh, I do this for a few
reasons. One, narrating my thoughts kind
of helps me focus. And uh second of all,
it allows me to kind of run support for
Puffer Libid and uh to help people to
get involved with the project and help
on all the open source stuff in real
time. So it makes it just really easy
overall. I usually have a much better
streaming setup than this, but I'm
traveling so uh I'm doing the Scuf
laptop setup on my crashy laptop.
Hopefully it's stable enough.
What are we learning today?
We're working on Hang on. Let me see if
I can run the thing. was actually drone
swarm.
Yeah. Okay. So, we have a sim. It has a
whole bunch of different drones in it
and we are working on having uh one
simulator that can race drones on
arbitrary race courses uh fly into
specific formations, follow targets,
basically do all sorts of different
things.
And also with different types of drones
as well. Same neural net, same sim.
That's what we're doing.
Are you going to be at ICML? No, I will
be at RLC though.
RLC is in a few weeks. I still have to
make the poster for that. But Puffer 2.0
was accepted to RLC. So, I'll be
presenting.
What I did is I'm going to make the
poster for Puffer 3.0 know cuz it's
pointless to put effort into making a
poster on something outdated. But I'm
not going to update the paper because
I'm not going to submit like a camera
ready that is a different paper from the
one that was reviewed.
But I will be there. I'll be handing out
puffer fish stickers and uh I'll be
chatting with people.
I'm trying to remember where I left this
thing off.
Yeah, I did use this one. Cool.
Hello, Alexand Alexander.
I've increased squared size to 22 and
agent is not learning.
What do you think they're missing?
Well, it's just really sparse.
So like you'd have to tune you'd have to
tune other things for that. Basically
you're going to need you actually you've
taken a simple environment and you've
actually made it hard when you do that
because you basically you have to luck
into the sequence of 40 moves that gets
you to the target randomly.
Yeah. But the thing is you have to this
is part of the article that you should
read, right? So what happens when you
increase increase size? All right, if
you look at the problem, it's not any
harder for you. You already know how to
solve it. When you're training from
scratch, you make the problem
exponentially harder because now the
agent has to luck into finding the
target and it has to luck into finding
the target a few times and then it has
to credit assign back 40 steps. So it's
very easy to build things that look easy
because of your intuition. But what you
have to do is you have to think about
starting from scratch as a naive
exploration problem. How hard is this?
That's the trick.
That's part I think I mentioned stuff
like this in my No, I actually this is
in like all my best advice in one place.
I gave you that information in that
section.
Pretty much everything that I can tell
you is going to be in that guide in some
form. So, what I I think I'm going to do
from now on is I'm going to answer all
these questions, but I'm also going to
point people to where it is in the guide
because it's like it's the type of thing
where all the information is there, but
you're not going to draw the
connections, I suppose, until you see it
like you see it in practice in a couple
places.
I'm trying to remember where the heck I
left off on this thing.
Long way from lunar lander.
It's too fun. I don't want to rush too
fast.
So, here's the thing.
Don't, if you're starting out, don't use
one of the slow environments to learn.
Like, don't use one of the very slow
environments when you're learning cuz
it's just going to it's going to make
the process of doing everything really
painful.
Like, use Snake.
Sound is rippling.
Well, it's not going to be as high
quality as my other setup. I have a $200
audio setup here. I have a $1,000 audio
setup there.
I'm also streaming this from my bedroom
with like a green screen, so it's it's a
small echoey room. If anybody has better
compressor settings, like go for it. But
I can at least maybe move the mic a
little closer. It'll be in the shot
here. We'll move the puffer. We'll move
the uh the puffer. He likes to cover the
camera. I mean, he likes to cover the
microphone.
And then I can probably mic it down just
a little bit.
Okay. Yeah, I remember where we were
now.
I kind of got off track
because I had I had like four or five
meetings yesterday as well as like all
the release stuff with the article. So,
I sort of forgot what I was building
with this, but um we were working on
getting the two different drone sims,
the multi- aents forming sim and the
racing sim together into the same sim
without making a mess out of everything
in the process. And uh I think I had
just about gotten that to run.
Hopefully this doesn't lag or crash
though. We'll see.
I tried to sweep
take on learning fair enough in two
weeks.
Uh it's going to depend dramatically on
your starting point.
If you're competent at low-level
engineering, then you will be able to do
the first several sections of my guide
in two weeks, and you will be able to
like you'll be able to build something
on the level of an arcade game and get
it to train with RL in two weeks.
Okay. So, this lags the hell out of
everything. So, um what we're going to
do is we're going to put this on I'm
going to commit this stuff and we're
going to try to put this on the bigger
box so that I can have this not lag my
local.
Mildly inconvenient, but we'll do it
this way.
I don't super like doing it this way
because I'm going to have to sync
constantly and
if like I crash that other machine I'm
going to lose work because I'm not there
in person.
Let me go pick. I also don't know why
this thing doesn't catch my credentials.
Supposed to
Joseph got a minute. Uh depends what you
what do you want to uh what do you
I actually don't even know where my
token went. What the hell?
That's annoying. Give me a clue to find
some good hyperparams. If you're going
to scale the environment that up, you're
probably going to have to increase the
batch size over whatever defaults I
used.
I don't exactly remember, but I think I
used substantially smaller batch size
because that task was like trivial.
You've made it non-trivial.
So, you're going to have to actually use
like the big boy hyperparams.
It's very easy to do things like this.
Like you make a problem that looks easy
to you, but if you actually think about
it for two seconds from a a first
principal's perspective instead of a
from oh, it's easy for me, so it should
be easy for the AI, right? Like you'll
see why the thing doesn't make sense.
Right? This puffer is kind of in my
face. I'll I'll let the microphone be in
the frame. He can be up there
to sweep. Try different batch size. It
depends on the configuration.
You can look at the defaults to see what
gets swept.
I don't actually remember.
I think that if you have the batch size
set to auto, but the BPT horizon is
swept, then it does get swept. Um,
I also don't remember how I did the OB
space for squared. Like, it may or may
not make sense for that as you scale.
Like, it wasn't intended to be scaled to
that size. It was meant as like a really
stupid simple like simple demo
environment.
It's a perfectly reasonable thing to do
actually if you want to like if you want
to make it try to if you want to try to
make it work on large boards. You can
absolutely like you can absolutely do
that. You're going to have to think
about it though, right? Because you you
changed the problem substantially.
I got to go grab my phone to verify
GitHub. I don't know why it stops
capping my credentials
just randomly.
I think legion observation doesn't tell
me much. You probably
it probably needs to either know like
delta 2
like if if I did it the way I do most
things which is just like a local crop
that's going to be hard.
sweep.go goals. I believe there's a
maximize and a minimize option
or there's a there's a metric I it
depends like there's a metric that's
like the thing that the sweep tries to
improve and then there's a direction
that tells you whether it's bigger or
smaller
I don't know why GitHub keeps making the
like the authentication uh the
authentication worse and worse.
Super annoying.
Okay, this
How is the RL coming today? Did you get
the drone stop done? Nope. I ended up
having like three extra meetings
and uh that's about it.
Now that works.
Dev on the uh the puffer box.
This it will be mildly annoying to
render things,
but we will uh we'll start with this at
least.
I really should just get the remote
rendering to work at some point.
What's the difference between num
workers and batch size?
So numbum workers is going to multiply
the num ms or num agent setting. Num
workers is the number of CPU cores that
you're going to use to train.
It's going to affect the batch size and
also the simulation speed.
Give us some logs on Neptune.
Oh, hey Kevin. How's it going?
Dang it. Let me restart this container.
Lovely.
Pretty much every single tool I use,
like every tool that I ever add will
always have at least one major issue
with it. With Docker, it's dropping
GPUs.
For folks who just got here, we are
working on training some drones today.
I have a a racing environment and I have
a swarm environment that work
separately. I'm trying to make like one
environment and have just one policy
that can do pretty much whatever it
wants with the drone.
that's got to be for pi squ or something
because it wouldn't make sense
otherwise. That's saying that for
Okay.
You probably don't need quite that many.
Probably I would do like
I usually do like numms is 1024 and
numbum workers is like eight
if you have an 8 core CPU.
Okay. Yeah, something is definitely
wrong here. The fact that it's just
capped on Perf like this, right?
Yeah. Like look at this.
So I must have just broken something,
right?
The episode length increasing
out of bounds is super high.
Recently discovered your work. It's
great. Thank you.
Yeah, I stream all my devs. So
usually here just hanging out and
building stuff.
self-studied 336. 336 did not exist when
I was an undergrad there. Um I assume
it's like language model stuff. Oh, is
that the language model from Scratch
course?
I saw that
it looked kind of okay.
It was sort of weird in some ways. It
was like too high level in places and
like too low level in others.
It looked decent.
Like the fact I think that they go to
Triton and don't actually have you do
cuda, which is kind of annoying
if I recall. course didn't exist when I
was uh in undergrad.
CS231N is like a really good base for
deep learning.
But I mean, if you can do 336, then you
should already know that stuff.
language model reinforcement learning.
Honestly, it's kind of like really baby
mode reinforcement learning in the sense
that like there's really not that much
interesting or uh interesting or complex
stuff happening in reinforcement
learning for language models. Uh and the
thing that makes it hard is just
everything is really slow.
So, it's kind of a tough space to be in
if you don't just have tons of GPUs.
what we're doing here lets us study a
lot of different RL methods and there's
a lot more there's a lot more stuff
going on in the research here and it's
cool that like we can actually do all
this work uh very very quickly without
having to have a huge number of GPUs
which is why I'm doing things this way
so if you're interested in like RL more
deeply outside of just language models I
would definitely suggest looking at um
more general RL because language models
is like it's the all the hype at the
moment but it's very it's really one
very small piece of what RL is going to
be able to do. I don't even think
language models are necessarily going to
be the most impactful application of RL
maybe depends.
Thanks.
How to set batch size auto on sweep on
any file. Yes. So this is one of the
annoying things. you have to just delete
it from the default or comment it from
the default. It's one of the things I'm
not super happy with.
Most of the stuff, not everything, there
are things I can absolutely improve in
puffer liib, but a lot of the stuff like
that where like, well, why is it that
way? It's because the uh the fix that
people have proposed and all the
possible fixes I've thought of for this
are way worse than just having it be the
way that it is.
batch size equals n.
No, no, you just you comment the whole
section like the whole sweep.
Uh, wait. Sweep.
None of that syntax is correct. It's
like sweep.train.batch size and then you
comment that block. That's interesting.
What could possibly more impactful? What
LMS without LM? What other sources of
strong pre to RL on? See, this is the b
like this is the bubble that most of AI
is in right now is everyone's just
thinking about LLMs. Like all of
logistics,
um any fiddly optimization process where
language models make no sense because if
you think of a language model as like
having a a smart person look at the
problem and try to solve it, there are a
lot of fiddly unintuitive problems where
you just need to chug a whole bunch of
data. Um
any sort of low fidelity control and
we're getting to do higher fidelity
control. That's more of a simulation
problem than a learning problem.
There's so so many problems outside of
language models.
Basically, all of Silicon Valley with
language models at the moment is just
we're racing to see who can build God
first. And uh you know, we'll see if
that actually works out. But
my uh I currently think two to one it's
likely that LM get stuck at a certain
point.
Uh yeah, except it's not going to be min
as one, mean as 8. It's like, you know,
65,000,
128,000, 256,000.
It's probably going to be a uni. It's
probably going to be like a uniform pow.
I think we literally have it in there,
don't we?
Okay, so here's mini batch size.
Okay, so batch size is auto at the
moment and the way it works, so batch
size gets set based on BPT Horizon for
you. Batch size is going to be equal to
BPTT horizon uh times the total number
of environments or the total number of
agents. So there you go.
I set this thing to be the flag task,
right?
Did I like break the observations or
something?
Finn is one of the two authors of the
original drone environment that I'm
hacking on here.
They did all the physics that
drives me crazy.
Drone lib updates to PR later. Cool.
Yeah, I'm trying to fix a whole bunch of
stuff for you guys. What about
multi-turn RL stuff? So, this is what I
mean about RL being like in LM's being
total baby mode, right? Multi-turn RL is
the default in the entire rest of RL.
Like a multi-turn, how about like a,000
turns or 10,000 turns, right? That's
what we deal with by default all the
time on one GPU.
So it's like LM like the LLM people here
are very slowly rediscovering
like the extreme basics of what we do in
reinforcement learning. It's not just
cuz it's like stupid, right? It's just
cuz everything is so slow there that
nothing works like nothing works
essentially.
So like the capabilities you're seeing
LLMs get out of reinforcement learning
it's a tiny tiny fraction of what RL can
do.
If a pram is not in P square, does it
take it from defaults? Yes, it does.
That is why those are called defaults.
[Music]
I'm trying like what I what could I have
possibly broken this badly?
Let's check it on the local real quick.
We'll uh we'll use the remote for
running more experiments.
I'm being a little bit dismissive, I
suppose, Kevin, of some of the stuff in
LM, like some of the work in LM's at the
moment. It's not that like people aren't
doing good work. It's it's just kind of
obnoxious to see people like it's like
they're sort of rediscovering everything
that we've been working on for decade in
reinforcement learning and like acting
like it's all brand new stuff when it's
just absolutely not.
So, I'm kind of pulling a little bit of
a schmid hoover here, but um I mean we
actually have the stuff working like
outside of LLMs and it works very well
now and it was and it's built on like a
decade plus of Perfect.
I just want to see if they control.
Okay, they do control here.
Have you explored many open-ended
algorithms? There aren't there aren't
any open-ended algorithms.
It's a research branch. There aren't but
there aren't any actually open-ended
algorithms.
The goal of the branch is to create s
like to create such algorithms.
Also, so here there's like There's
actually a problem
with a lot of open-ended learning as
it's defined because it's typically
defined as like, hey, if we left this
thing running for 10,000 years, would it
continue to produce more and more
interesting results, right? Well, the
thing is,
if you just write faster code, it's
going to saturate faster, right? So like
neural MMO for instance, uh it keeps
getting better over 12,000 years of
gameplay. It's just that it's so fast
that we're able to run that in 3 days.
Like if I ran if I had this thing
running at the speed of the rest of the
field, yeah, we could literally say that
neural MMO is an open-ended system that
continues to learn for like years and
years of training, right?
Why does policy gradients work at all?
It seems very non-obvious and
non-intuitive compared to what?
Like the derivation for getting
gradients from reward. It's like a
fiveline derivation, right?
You mash random buttons. Eventually, you
luck into some rewards and you attempt
to do credit assignment for which random
buttons you mash got to which rewards.
Can I ask dumb questions? We use RL.
Well, yeah, of course.
I must have totally broken something
here, huh?
Oh, here it is. I see it. I see it. It's
right here.
That was silly.
Accidentally copied like this snippet
from the other environment that was
single agent.
You know, so open-ended learning is
really cool, Brad, but like
they've got to fix that. Like they've
got to patch that bug with it. And if
you think about it,
I mean, you can really think of a lot of
my PhD as that. I just didn't frame it
that way. For me, like the best RL
environment that we can build for
research is just a really fast MMO.
And if you look at what I've done with
Neural MMO 3 and you watch the agents on
the website for a while, I mean, we have
they're really good mechanically. They
know how to kite enemies. They know how
to estimate the difference. Like they
can estimate what foes are too strong
for them. They can use tools. Like they
can go get and equipped items, armor,
they can use consumables, all sorts of
things. They can sell and buy things
with each other on a global market. And
like the policy can actually do all
this. It's pretty crazy.
How often do you stream? I stream pretty
much all my Dev Kevin. So, like usually
I stream six days a week except for the
fact that I also have a bunch of random
meetings scattered throughout and stuff.
And I also I mean lately I've been just
I've done so much stuff that I've been
taking a little time off to recoup from
all the stuff I've built recently. But,
uh, it's generally anywhere from 30 to
70. I've actually I've probably done
anywhere from 30 to 80 hours of
streaming a week,
just like um, Monday through Saturday.
Typically,
even with variance reduction, RL just
seems so inherently noisy
for any meaningfully highdimensional
task. Uh, so here's a fun stat.
So GPT4 was trained on an estimated 13
trillion tokens, right? Tokens for
bytes. So 50ish 52
uh terabytes of data. Yeah, we train
neural MMO 3 on a pabyte of data. And
that's if you're using the compressed
form. Otherwise, it's like six pabytes
of data on a single server.
So
we can just massively scale data.
It's also not exactly reinforced
anymore. Like
there's quite a bit of stuff now that
makes it work, right?
Generalized advantage estimation is very
important.
Uh the clip term and PO is very
important. Some of our innovations that
we've added on top of this are very
important.
So, what did this thing just do?
It learned something,
but it didn't
doesn't look like it's doing a flag.
Hey bet.
How's it going, man?
Puffer.
It's puffer. Max Jar is at buffer max
one
could not resolve. I misspell it.
I really need to just get the remote
rendering thing to work.
Hang on, I miss some messages. Should I
do a P RL PhD or go into industry? Just
graduated undergrad. I only suggest I
only suggest that people who know that
they want to do a PhD do PhDs.
Probably the most interesting things now
are either to try to be able to join
like one of the uh the bigger labs, one
of the ones that actually moves at a
decent pace if you can get an offer
there and if not would be to go join
some cool startup that's doing literally
anything other than making a GPT rapper.
Do you think the objective functions we
define are the main problem achieving
truly generalized intelligence? No, not
really.
It's mostly a bottleneck in the way that
research is done because everything was
too slow.
It's pretty much like
all the research in RL that was done in
the last 10 years was essentially set up
to fail because everything was too slow.
We've fixed that now, but that still
leaves us with 10 years worth of
research to catch up on.
Hey T. said, "Well,
I thought you're bearish on LM." I give
LLMs a one in three chance at solving
everything. If that's considered
bearish, then like sure.
The my main perspective here, Kevin, is
everybody else is already doing LLMs.
So, like whatever is going to happen in
that space is already going to happen.
There all these other interesting areas
of AI where like LMS have essentially
brain drained all the talent from these
areas. But it's not like these areas are
not promising, right? Like all the cool
stuff happening in reinforcement
learning is uh like like all the stuff
that's happening in reinforcement
learning now is real and legit. Like
it's just that there was nobody doing
this stuff correctly and uh that's what
I'm doing now myself.
I don't know. Everyone sees this C and
like oh yeah it's so hardcore is like
the C. It's like no. This is literally
the easiest thing. I don't do this cuz
it's hard. I do it because it's easy.
Arl needs a lot of work. Needs lots of
work. We pretty much have the whole plan
now, honestly, for how to do this stuff.
I'm taking a little bit of a break from
doing the um the next wave of pure
algorithm dev in order to build out
Puffer Lib as a company a little bit
more. You know, this needs to expand a
little bit. We don't need to be huge,
but I need to have like at least a
decent size, like a decent little
private lab. And then I know exactly how
we're going to do it. It's it's pretty
much what we've already done already,
just applied on a slightly larger scale.
We're going to go back through the last
seven, eight years worth of deep mind
stuff, go strip out all the fiddly bits
that make stuff slow, figure out what
actually helps, and then look at like
off policy learning, world modeling, and
search and figure out from these how we
get a single RL algorithm where we can
crank up the data and have it learn
really, really fast without a ton of
compute. Or we can crank up the compute
and have it learn really fast in terms
of not using a lot of data in one
algorithm. that's not a horrible mess.
That's the goal.
What did I mess up here?
I thought that I'd fix this. No.
900. That seems large.
Error
copying.
This would be 512 size, wouldn't it?
512x4.
I didn't train 512 though. I trained
256.
Oh yeah. Know I think I know what uh
I know what happened, right?
No.
still. No.
Oh, no. Here, because I have to do Yeah,
I know how we'll do this. We'll just do
puffer tank docker. That'll save me a
step.
Holy.
Yeah. Okay. So, um
I might have slightly broken some stuff.
This is really freaking cool looking,
but uh this is not assembling into a
flag.
I think that uh for some reason I have
them like it looks like they move way
too fast.
So pretty much what I'm trying to do and
Tessa this is what I'm trying to do at
the moment. I made this demo where like
drones could assemble themselves into a
flag. They could assemble themselves
into a sphere. They could follow
targets. And we also have this other
demo where drones can let drones can
race through hoops like they can go
through hoops race. And we're going to
try to do one policy that can do all the
tasks like a tiny policy can do all the
tasks and um
also can do it with like different types
of drones as well. So different weights,
different sizes. And then we're going to
throw it on a real drone policy. And
because it's going to be super robust,
it should just zero shots into real.
That's going to be the goal. Yeah, this
to me this clearly looks like a dynamics
bug though. This looks like I broke
something in the environment somehow and
that is what is causing this. That is my
guess.
Isn't there still an inherent ceiling
even with the trip tricks on top of
policy gradient value learning? Why
would there be a ceiling? You have
unlimited ground truth data. What's the
input to drones seems outward or is a
list of uh it's like deltas in
positions, delta positions, delta
velocities,
um things like that.
It only is seeing it's seeing like 30 34
numbers I believe at the moment. It's
not a ton of data. Now, obviously when
we go to throw this on a real drone,
like if we want to do more than just
some cool aerial maneuvers, we'll have
to do a bit of perception, but I figure
we're going to be able to make a cool
enough demo and get some simil and then
that'll get some people interested in
wanting to work with us in this space.
We're kind of just doing this for a
bunch of different topics, like a bunch
of different industries at the moment is
we're just like building out cool demos,
uh trying to see if we can make RL
useful in different spaces and then
generally looking for contracts in these
areas. Also for anybody if you're
interested in getting involved with the
business side of Puffer, it's all
bootstrapped and contract based. So we
don't hire full-time, but if you have
experience in another area and you think
that we can make RL work in that area,
uh the best way to get involved is to
like build prototypes and help us find
companies in these spaces that would be
interested in applying RL to uh to new
problems. We cut you in on the contracts
for those.
That's generally how Puffer Lib works.
Holy, that is uh a lot of views on the X
stream, more than normal. I guess the
account got a lot bigger. You can't
actually see the number of concurrent
viewers on X, which is really obnoxious,
but uh to whichever new folks are here,
welcome. I do stream all of my RL dev
and all of my research.
Okay, so let's see why the drones are
going in a crazy loop like this.
It would have to be this thing, wouldn't
it? It's like a nit drone.
I didn't think I messed with that
though.
So, this is the function that does all
the randomizations.
Ash was saying he learned RL in two
weeks because of buffer li.
Yeah, that did help quite a bit. The
articles also uh the articles also have
done very very well.
like the articles are at uh like a
quarter million views on one and 300
some odd thousand on the other.
Carmarmac saying that the uh the
programming advice I gave was good
advice was pretty cool.
It's nice to see like other like like
other like really good programmers
saying yes, this is the way to do things
because
it's very easy to sort of get gas lit by
big industry into thinking that like the
way that software done is done there is
the correct way to build software. But
honestly like the way a lot of software
is built in big companies is just awful
these days. There's like and there's no
reason for it. It's just I I don't know
somehow best practice is worst practice.
efficient Marcus hypothesis my ass.
I don't know. It's weird. Now
Carmarmac's awesome.
I'm trying to see if I messed anything
up in here.
I don't think I did because like all
these things are relative scales, right?
like the base parameters are the same.
So if I put in the initial size, it
should give me the exact same parameters
as before.
Base arm length divided by No, this is
like all reasonable.
How did you learn figure learn and
figure out the right way of software and
reinforcement learning?
Uh
lots and lots and lots of writing bad
code and being very mad that the code
was bad for the most part. I tried
things in a huge number of different
styles. I did like a number of
experiments on like different ways to
build things that were really dumb but
like were important for learning.
And like using Rayb actually helped
quite a bit because like the way that
Ray is built is really really good.
I mean there are a few sources that have
been good. Um like the way that Clean RL
does stuff is really good but then
people discount it cuz like oh it
doesn't scale or whatever [ __ ] Like
Ray Lib is also really good but it's
also kind of like this natural problem
where it makes sense to do stuff that
way. So, it's like a not so natural
continuation of the way that other good
things that I like are built
and then just like lots and lots of
doing stuff in different ways and seeing
all the problems.
Try reducing it to one drone. The thing
is that I've literally had this problem
working. So, it is a straight up bug,
right? Like I've had this working
perfectly before. So, the fact that it
isn't means I've just straight up broken
something. I don't think it's a learning
problem. I think that somehow the motors
are too fast.
thoughts on exploration. Isn't that
still unsolved? It's not that it's
unsolved, it's that it's illposed.
Like honestly most like pretty much
everything under the branch of uh pretty
much all research under the branch of
exploration is in RL is wrong and it's
wrong at at the abstract because the
problem they're posing doesn't make any
sense.
VODs archived anywhere? Yes, they're
archived on YouTube. Um you can skip if
you see like short little one minute
VODs or whatever, you can skip those.
YouTube cuts the stream up like whenever
there's an internet blip or something
breaks. So, but generally you will see
there are lots of like many like
multi-hour VODs. It's going to be too
much content to possibly watch, mind
you, because I stream like anywhere from
30 to 80 hours of dev a week.
I've been a little lazy this week. Kind
of tired from all the stuff with 3 and
the articles and like you know business
stuff and all that.
I'm kind of just like building a few
drone stuffs, a few drone things and
having fun like building out a
a bigger like user base reper.
at Nural MMO. Yeah, I don't I've thought
about changing that handle, but I don't
know what I would change it to. Would I
just change it to like my J Suarez 5341?
I don't know.
I could just do that so I have the same
handle on everything. Thoughts on Jack's
based environments? Uh, major nerd
snipe. Do not do that.
The reason that you don't do that is
because it's like kind of okay for heavy
physics. You should probably be doing
something else at that point. But um the
problem with jacks based environments is
that you force yourself to write
everything as uh array based operations
to run it on the GPU when like you could
just write arbitrary logic in C, not
have to warp your mind into writing
everything as a series of array
operations and have everything be s
significantly easier and just as fast.
Jacks for environments was a really
really dumb decision and it was
motivated by people like it's crazy that
researchers are willing to do array
operation domain specific language that
looks like Python rather than just use
anything other than Python.
Just try the C. It's really really basic
C like first course in systems undergrad
level C. We're not doing anything
remotely smart at the moment. I promise
you.
What are the possibilities that like
what's even the error surface of this?
Like
Yeah, it is getting clamped, right? Max
velocity.
Why are the drones this big though?
Isn't that kind of sketchy?
Okay. Yeah, this is not what it should
look like.
The drones are like bigger than I would
expect them to be.
It doesn't need to be double knitted.
That's dumb, right?
But then
Yeah, the drones are too big. They're
not supposed to be that big.
visual arm length? We got rid of this.
Did I get rid of this in the racing end?
Did I just like forget what I was doing?
Okay, so I guess there are a few
possible error sources I have not
checked yet.
I'm just going to look for a zero
everywhere in here. It's going to be a
lot of them, but
getting a lot of views on X. So, the
annoying thing about X is um you can't
see concurrent viewers anywhere. So, I
have no idea how many concurrent viewers
it is versus just people scrolling
through the timeline.
I can see concurrent on Twitch and
YouTube.
We now have uh 14 on YouTube. Welcome
everyone. And uh two on Twitch.
Oh yeah, speaking of which, for new
folks here, this is all open source. So
like you can just get involved with
development right now. It's puffer.ai.
Just click the Discord. We have a whole
bunch of helpful people in there. Uh for
the YouTube folks who are new, you can
follow me on X. I post all sorts of RL
stuff there, including the new guides.
The new guides are there first. They'll
be on the website later. And if you want
to help me for free, just star the repo.
Got to star the puffer. You eat stars.
So I was the hypothesis here was that
like I had accidentally not reset
rewards or something or not reset
terminals like I maybe I'd only did it
for the first agent because this was
originally a single agent environment
but that doesn't seem to be the case
somehow. Now the drones are just like
super zippy fast.
I don't think it would make any sense
for this to be a learning bug, right?
I mean, the render is not great, but
that won't affect anything.
I did I test this with multi hang on.
Maybe I didn't test drone lib with
multi- aent.
How experienced do you have to be to get
involved? We literally have brand new
programmers.
It's just where you start off, right?
It's like initially you start off by
getting to the level where you can build
a basic environment. some of the basic
ones actually end up being useful for
research and then the high end of
experiences you can actually contribute
to like the core infrastructure or the
core research or stuff like that. Uh
there's also there's applications work
as well. I mean it's there are a ton of
different places that people can get
involved depending on your background
and what other things you know
cash brought me here. All I did in RL
was a segment in MIT Micro Masters.
Well, we have a lot of content around
here for people looking to get into it.
Super zippy fast might cause it to hit
the clamps when before it wasn't, which
could break derivative. So, I I would be
really surprised if it's a learning
problem. Like, I think that something is
different in the sim because this was a
big refactor, right? I took two
different SIMs and I basically I merged
the code together manually and uh I
think something is broken in the
process.
Hang on. So this this should be fine
because I pass a pointer to actions but
this is already offset correctly.
So like it can't it can't break because
of that I wouldn't think.
Let me just double check one more time
that I didn't mess this up somehow cuz
like
base arm length
is 0.1
and then this one gets scaled
mass arm squared.
The rest gets scaled by mass arm length.
It's fine.
And this gets scaled by average inertia.
Delta.
This gets scaled by drag.
Yeah. So all these should be one.
And these should all literally be one.
Technically they should be able to learn
this even if they are zippy fast, right?
Like they don't have to.
It's a continuous action. They're
allowed to go slower.
Could I have messed up rewards or
something instead?
Maybe it's rewards. That's also
possible.
Like I'm not setting the task correctly.
Maybe
But that was
wait reset agent
and you set the target.
No, I am setting the target here.
Why is Impala a bad architecture?
So it's not
the thing is that when people say impala
like they almost always just mean the
neural net architecture that
architecture is slow but it's fine the
thing is that the actual Impala paper is
not just that architecture the actual
Impala paper has a bunch of additional
algorithmic stuff and the key of it all
is vrace and vrace on its own is not
very good
I know this because I implemented and I
tested
Kevin, it's literally like you just you
go through the guide, you literally just
start building cool environments and
pring stuff and you work your way up to
more comp like more complicated and
interesting things. And if you have a
like even a halfway decent programming
background, you'll see that it's like
shockingly quick to get to the point
that you're actually doing things that
are already useful.
What do you think about RX infer? Never
heard of it.
I have the Discord. Well, to be fair, we
do have like quite a few people now at
this point, but yeah, Bett has been
around helping people for quite a while.
He gives advice that's usually correct.
What in the heck?
I hate it when I do this where I like
I still think that the way that I did
this originally was the right call like
to build a separate drone sim cuz I
didn't know how well this swarming stuff
was going to work and I didn't want to
make a mess of the original sim before I
knew that it would work. But man, is it
annoying to have to merge two things
like this?
Are there ways to make one agent that is
super good at a lot of environments?
Yes. Yes, there are.
Typically what you do is you do it's
better if you do lots of tasks instead
of lots of environments in the sense
that like you keep the observation and
action spaces relatively consistent but
you want them to do different things. Um
like we can just do that. It's not that
hard.
AIX
No. What is that?
What was the recent step change in RL
that we now know how to do stuff? One, I
made reinforcement learning like a
thousand plus times faster. So, we can
just actually run all the experiments
that we need to run very quickly. We
have lots of environments to test stuff
out on. And then there have been some
algorithmic improvements that have
generally made stuff a lot more stable,
including in hyperparameter sweep
tuning. But like if you read the puffing
up PO article which is linked by my uh
my new guide like it has all the
information like I literally outline all
the key stuff that we've done in puffer
lib and also all like the key relevant
stuff in the literature
fast environment to scale up. You don't
even need to do simal in a lot of
valuable problems Kevin like I I don't
understand what it is with Silicon
Valley. It's like the only problems that
exist to them are LLMs and robotics.
Okay, there are a ton of things that are
not LLMs and robotics.
What's the key breakthrough for a
th00andx? It's kind of sad to stop
writing really bad Python code and write
really dumb simple C.
I'm only slightly simplifying. Like,
yeah, we had to rewrite some key aspects
of the reinforcement learning stack to
not bottleneck you in the middle. Um,
but it's like 2,000 total lines of code
to just make the field work and nobody
did it for a decade.
It's that simple.
What's your opinion on XAI? Sounds cool.
It looks like they're doing cool stuff
with a relatively small team.
They're spending more money on GPUs to
catch up quickly though, right? Like
they have a small team and they're just
they're spending more money on compute
so that they can catch up more quickly
because it's a newer lab.
Other labs have a lead. I haven't read
the new Ken Stanley paper yet. know
I need to at some point and I do not
have more energy than those guys to be
honest with you.
There are definitely people who work
harder than me these days.
I'm like decent. Like I'm pretty decent
but like I don't do it for months on
end. I kind of like I'll do like a few
weeks of really hard work at a time and
then like I go do like more moderate
work and I think about stuff for a few
weeks until I come up with the next
thing to do.
Hnet
hypernets. What?
Honestly, bet the thing I got to do at
the moment, which is probably the most
important, is I got to just go find when
I go to Palo Alto, I got to go get a PT
so I can like fix my knee and fix my
shoulder and like get my exercise
routine back proper again. That's like
the most important for me energywise.
Yeah, I know.
Do I know Ye Joe? No, I don't.
I don't think I do. At least
thoughts on Muan?
I'm going to just read that as I'm going
to choose to read that as Joseph. Yeah,
we Muan's really good. It's in puffer li
hierarchical network replaces
tokenization with dynamic trunking.
I'm not going to have good comments for
you on like random LLM research, right?
I do not stay current with like whatever
is happening on LM development. It's too
much stuff to follow. I only stay
current on my exact area.
Started his PhD at Berkeley and
reasoning is now at XAI. Research is
crazy. Sounds cool.
I don't know. I chatted with a couple of
the XAI guys last summer since I was in
the area.
The only thing I don't like is the
Rustin Type script stack. I'll forgive
the jacks because of the scale, but like
uh mess.
What's your research area? The stuff you
see me doing here. I do high performance
reinforcement learning, not LLM
reinforcement learning, right?
Have you gotten into some defense
applications in Puffer Lib? Have you
gotten uh not yet, but that's like one
of the things we can do with the drones,
right?
Or else or else it is then. Can you tell
me what I can build to just get an
exposure of RL? So, if you just go to my
X account, there are it's like 25 plus
pages actually with all the other
materials. It's probably like 40 pages
worth of relatively easy to read content
that will tell you exactly step by step
how to get into all of this stuff and
what to read and how to learn.
Oh, does Kimmy use Muan? Yeah, Muan's
pretty good.
What in the heck did I do to this thing,
man?
Do I actually need to run it with one
drone? It's literally not even set up
for that now at this point.
No, it kind of is, isn't it?
Maybe I can just do it.
Do you have a Google doc of environments
currently being built?
Uh, nope.
We have the stuff that's on the website
is like partially complete.
Can ask around in the Discord as well.
I'm building some cool stuff rocket
based and I'd love to run by you. If
you're doing rockets plus RL, that is
awesome. And that's like people who have
experience in applications in other
areas. That's like the that's the type
of stuff we are the most interested to
work with like out of anything.
It's also how you do business stuff with
us. If you can like help us bring RL to
a new area.
Is using GPUs for RL more difficult
because time steps are not necessarily
independent
and we can't easily paralyze everything.
It is more difficult. It's not exactly
for that reason that you mentioned and
uh yeah we had to optimize everything
like we basically we care about overhead
that is a thousandth of the amount of
overhead that everybody else has to care
about if that makes sense or less.
So like if you go ah you know we're
losing half a second in between updates
doesn't matter. Our updates take like a
minute. No we care about milliseconds.
Kimmy showed Muan works better than Adam
W.
Uh that's been known for a while though.
Like that's not new. Like it literally
we did that for um we've done that for
puffer lip 3.0. We've had this in for
months.
What's your AGI timeline? I don't know.
As soon as I finish building it,
right?
Did I mess with the observations in a
way that would break it
like this? 1 2 3 four five six. I
counted this very carefully though.
What works better?
A mu on
I gotta actually read through this and
figure out what the heck is going on
because I don't want to be stuck on this
all day. This is like pretty silly.
Why it's so incredibly difficult to
learn in a physical environment. It's
just that the Sims are slow. That's
literally it.
I got the article. Thanks you and SF
right now. No, but I will be in Palo
Alto from the 16thish until
reinforcement learning comp and then I
will be back after that conference in
Palo Alto for a good chunk of the rest
of the summer. I will take a few trips
to SF, but I'm not like I'm not going to
take a ton of like individual meet trips
up to SF. I will do meets in like
Mountain View, Palo Alto, generally the
surrounding area. And I will plan like a
I will plan like a few like bookended
days in SF as well. Contributions
in other areas have to fit within puffer
liib or are there other ways to exchange
ideas? What do you mean by that?
Like the stuff we do is generally
reinforcement learning, core
infrastructure for reinforcement
learning, core algorithm research, and
then applications on a ton of different
domains.
We also do like high perf sim work.
That's kind of our wheelhouse.
meta and open coaching, bro. It's just
normal company stuff, man. There's not
even any drama. That's just companies
being companies.
Where's the home gym background? I'm in
Florida at the moment. I don't have well
actually I do have home gym here. It's
not as good of a one but I I do have one
here but it's not in my room literally
unfortunately
I'm just going to like
Wait, set target.
Wait. Set target. N I
No, this is going to be fine, right?
Ah, screw it. We'll just do this real
quick.
I don't think that's going to do
anything.
everyone contributing to power have a
bench 225.
No, but I do suggest that uh at least
men do attempt to be able to do that
because it is generally good for your
health and you will feel better about a
lot of things.
I'm very sad that I can't I can barely
bench the bar right now because of my
shoulder. Before I hurt my shoulder, I
was doing like 210 for 10 hold.
Is it reasonable to run po on an M2?
You can do it and it'll still run like
the simpler M will still run one to
300,000 steps per second. It's just not
going to be as good as a GPU obviously.
Welcome Khan.
Puff Ben for RL and math.
Uh you'd have to do it purely
symbolically, right?
you'd have to do if you were to look at
like um like whatever the syntaxes that
are used for formal theorem provers, you
might be able to do something like that.
It's an area I've thought a little bit
about, but not too much.
Yeah, we do have a guy working on like a
touring machine and it's kind of funny
It's pretty much the tokenization that's
tricky, right? Like I don't know how you
tokenize it.
Welcome Kevin. I assume that's you on
you again on Twitch.
Okay. See, so this thing is actually
it's learning.
It's learning to not go out of bounds.
It's mostly learning to not collide.
not learning to get to the target
somehow.
Ting machine is hard. Yeah. No, I
wouldn't suggest you try to solve stuff
through touring machines for like like
integrals through touring machines.
That's ridiculous.
But even like just generally coming up
with a tokenization for that's kind of
tough.
I'm going to count this randomly because
I don't know what else to do. 4 3 6 9
19 22
Yeah. 34
34 OBS.
You just do Abstract syntax syntax tree.
Uh maybe
how would you train an agent to play the
game of 24
what GPUs most of my ML training work
experience using run pod.
Uh we do vast and hyperbolic when we
rent stuff but we mostly have our own
GPUs. We have 20 uh 20 4090s for Puffer.
Uh recurring contributors do actually
get access to our hardware for free. By
the way, we do actually give some people
access to our hardware to help with
Puffer Lib.
Not brand new people who are just like,
"Hey, I want to do something. Can I get
GPU access, though?" No, it's like if
you're actually building stuff and
contributing, then you get some access.
Uh box [ __ ] So Bach 6 is their bet, but
guess what? It happened to arrive a few
days after I left. So it's now in
Maryland and there is
maybe I could get somebody to just
unpack it and plug it in. Maybe.
I don't know.
Do I want to have somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing do that? Not
really. But if you're dying for another
box, I can probably
probably get somebody to do it.
like the people who are there do not
know what a GPU is. So,
what the heck did I possibly break? Did
I just start going through a diff of
this?
No, it's not going to be a difficult,
right?
Let's try this. Let me see if it's
something with the targeting.
Yeah, I know. Bet. This is what happens
when I code stuff while I'm distracted.
I was kind of doing the article stuff
the meantime yesterday.
Do you recommend Syon C or C++ for my
definitely see unless you have a very
good reason to do something else.
Sharp's doing RL and infosc.
A lot of different interactions.
Uh I'd have to learn more about the
space. We could probably do something
pretty good for that though.
I don't know about that Dan
or bet it's like
you could RL over very short assembly
programs without needing any sort of
language understanding I suppose but not
over like reading arbitrary source code.
It's not a clearcut slam dunk to me.
It's like a Yeah, maybe that's a good
application.
It's doing the same thing here, isn't
it?
It's the exact same thing as before,
though
exploitation.
Yeah. Well, you if it depends on the
domain, right? If you're talking about
like like short shell code exploits, you
might be able to RL over that type of a
thing.
It's an application. not a super easy
application. There would have to be
there'd have to be like a sizable
interest for me to want to do that stuff
or we'd have to have somebody who really
wanted to like spearhead it.
would need to understand like yeah if
you can build a fast enough sim it will
be able to do that type of stuff maybe
I mean heck the students don't
understand ASLR right usually when you
teach cyber sec you teach you just turn
that stuff off initially at least
I know shell code is a like unintuitive
fiddly optimization process. So probably
Take a look at the Discord gen chat.
Yeah.
Cool. What is this
track? Oh, is this the a This is the
audio thing, right? Cool.
That looks fun.
This guy's actually doing uh some
algorithm work for us which is very
nice.
Algorithm work is very helpful. There
not that many people who are qualified
to do it but if you are it's very
helpful for us. What about the M
Yeah, the OB space is fine.
None of these things are wrong.
I don't have some dumb config, right?
That's a reasonable config.
I didn't screw up the learning rate.
I didn't.
I'm going to go look at the old uh the
old code from before I broke this
and see how different this was. Holy
stars, she's doing well.
I think this was good here, right? Yeah,
we still had it working when we had
this, right? So if I just look at drone
swarm,
it's just nice to see this stuff finally
starting to take off a little. I mean,
this all happened pretty much as soon as
we actually we built something really
good with the Rio and we start like I
actually started spending some time
telling people about it
plus the educational material. It always
does well.
I mean, there is not anybody I will back
under my uh over myself on if you're
talking about purely on like how to
advance the field. What's the philosophy
on model size to use?
Bigger models be better. Uh so just by
default, we just throw a 128 hidden dim
LSTM plus whatever the encoder and
decoder size is going to be. for that
and then we scale it up if we can't
solve the problem with a small model or
if we see it being helpful a lot of
problems that you would think oh yeah we
need big networks that they just solve
with a really small model
are there scaling laws for RL kind of
at the very least it's pretty clear
though that like
you can you use a lot more data for any
given model size for RL Oh.
Interested in what I messed with with
the uh the step function
and such.
So reset's the same here, right?
Yeah. Reset. We're resetting spawn
velocity omega
turnian position. Yeah, this is all the
same.
We can get rid of the
Oh, no. We need the init. Do we need
this?
Try while I'm reading this. I'm going to
just try something silly
and see if that does anything different.
Does protein include model size?
So, we've done a few things with that
before.
It's a little tricky to do, but yes, you
can do that. So, it's protein will sweep
whatever you tell it to sweep. You can
include model size if you want.
It's one of the things I've been meaning
to put more time into really. That was
kind of a copout answer before.
we really haven't changed anything that
should matter at all.
Really haven't.
use the restroom real quick and grab
myself a new drink and we will keep on
uh figuring out what the heck is wrong.
I'd really like to get the uh the drone
environment working reasonably today.
That would just be a nice bit of
progress. Yeah, before I do that, how's
the um
how is the uh the Twitter doing?
I'm curious if it's still doing uh any
numbers. Oh yeah,
tons of notifications. It turns out
Wait, I forgot to ask. Are you saying we
should do all of our LMC? No,
we've got PyTorch.
So we actually here Kevin, we have both.
Our main training code is in PyTorch.
All right. So it's it's not like insane.
But then we also have this. Oops. Let me
not do that because I need this tab. And
then I and then I do need to use a
restroom and I'll be right back. Like I
need a couple minutes to go do some
things. But um look,
puffernet.h one file 700 something
lines. This implements all of the layers
that we commonly use uh exactly the same
way as they're done in PyTorch.
So this is like an LSTM and C. It's less
than 100 lines, right? It's like I don't
know 60 lines or something. And uh we
use this strictly for our web demos. So
how do you run neural nets on the
website, right? You can't just run
PyTorch models there easily. uh this
gets compiled to web assembly and this
runs in your browser and we just load
the weights in from the trained PyTorch
models. We don't do training and see
but it kind of shows goes to show you
that like
you can sort of just do stuff like this.
Be right back.
Is there a limit to what you'd attempt
to use puffer to solve?
Say something has a huge set of
observations.
You estimate RL sol. So there are two
questions there, right? There's would
you use puffer and would you use RL?
So anything that's like the type of RL
we deal with like on policy stuff,
there is not better RL software out
there for anything like oh we need
something that scales. You're going to
start with Puffer anyways cuz there's
nothing that works that does scale.
Um
as for things that like are not good
fits for RL like are beyond the
limitations of what we can reasonably do
with a reasonable amount of time and
effort. Yeah, of course. Right.
It's a lot about the first principles of
what do the observations look like for
this? How hard does the problem feel
from first principles exploration?
That sort of a thing.
So, I definitely didn't break anything
with this. This is all exactly the same
as it was before.
Something else.
Let's try the initialization stuff.
I don't know why my autocomplete is not
working.
Would you say RL agents are truly
creative?
Um,
it's kind of irrelevant.
It's like there's not a way to frame
that question in a way that really makes
any sense or is use or where the answer
would be useful.
It's like, oh, it was it like creative
to come up with move 37 or whatever or
did it just do like massive search? Like
it kind of doesn't matter because the
result is it made move 37? And like I
honestly I can't even that result
doesn't make sense to me and it's not
going to make sense to anyone unless
you're a very good Go player. Like the
one that made sense to me was like Dota
I think more than anything made sense to
me.
What do you think about John Carmarmac's
approach to RL in his recent
presentation? I love Carmarmac and I
love all the stuff that he does, but um
yeah, they're basically doing the
opposite thing to me. And it's not that
sample efficiency isn't important. It's
just like they're doing it in a way
that's going to make everything really
hard on themselves.
We're doing everything from the
perspective of make everything really
fast so you have a very quick dev cycle
and you can run massive numbers of
experiments. Then use your ability to
run massive numbers of experiments to
work on sample efficiency with actual
extensive validation.
This is the approach that I would
suggest.
Honestly, like what I'd love to see
Carmarmac do, right, is use like his
low-level gamedev wizardry to make some
ludicrously fast but actually complex,
interesting game tasks for us to use to
advance all of our L, right? Like I'm
sure Carmarmac could come take a look at
Neural MOO 3, right? like my main thing.
Look at Neural MMO 3 and he could
probably whip up a a neural MMO 4 that
would knock your socks off and would
actually let us make some crazy RL
breakthroughs.
Yeah, I don't know if there would be
one, Dan, because he's kind of like
doing his own RL lab thing with Sutton.
I also have nothing against Sutton.
Like, of course, he's godfather of
reinforcement learning, right?
They're doing great work. It's just that
the the thing that I'm seeing as a
bottleneck is just a very different way
of approaching the field than has been
done previously.
I'm not telling people like never read
Sutton and Bardau or never like think
about sample efficiency. It's just not
the ordering and the like the priorities
and things are completely wrong
when most people are introduced to the
field.
See in some of the replies we're clearly
seeing the way things Yeah. But if you
look at overall the feedback on the
article and stuff has been massively
positive.
Yeah, there are very few things like
this, right?
I'm going to do mass mass scale. Oh, I
didn't do this.
see if this does anything different.
I don't think it will, but maybe
some drone lip changes. I'm currently
trying to think figure out what I've
broken, Finn, cuz the drone swarm is not
fixing. Uh, I will absolutely take the
physics upgrades as soon as I get this
thing stable for you.
I'm working on getting you guys like a
really really good
sim that'll just zero shot to reel
everything.
such a huge stream of stuff on this
actually going to be at a 5k like I mean
15k soon. That's like that's ridiculous.
You don't understand what I've done.
What have you done?
Okay. Yes. This this was not it either.
So, it wasn't the randomization
buffer.
much puffer.
You were tagged as the puffer procelite
in the discord, right?
What do we do with this?
Is there like a max
Yeah, I just I broke some stuff and I'm
fixing it for you first and then I will
merge all that. Fin. I have to make sure
I get it to reproduce the previous
result first and then I will be able to
start merging the new things in.
I broke some crap.
That's why it wasn't working.
It wasn't active.
You know, I am kind of suspicious
actually that
something else could have broken
like before I did any of this maybe
if this one doesn't work, then there's
definitely
way more
You know, instead of just sitting here
while I'm uh I should go through all
these new messages
doing this.
I have to check that N thing for that
guy at some point. I need to fix this
first.
It's failing. Hover. Hover is a very
easy touch.
did I just like
telepathy that like what the heck?
Oh, is it?
No.
Hang on. If task is task erase
else.
Does anybody see the dumb thing I'm
doing?
chest is at 1.5k. What are you doing,
man?
Like something is very very very wrong
if you're getting 1.5k SPS.
Okay. I don't understand how this is
better. Something is
something be messing with this task
variable somehow.
is it just a fluke? Like,
okay, maybe this is just a fluke. That's
So, it did learn to hover like once
and then it was unstable.
Let's make sure this is actually
building.
This is building, right?
There is this slight curve difference
which is weird.
Well, the thing is they are learning to
not collide
quite well.
which is actually a harder problem than
what I'm telling them to
I wouldn't think any of this should
matter.
Well, this is just going to be one of
those slow days where I have to like put
in the work to get this thing to
actually um
simulate correctly.
Most of the hard work in RL is making
your sim actually be correct anyways.
Yeah. So, this is just initializing
things. This wouldn't matter. Let's just
let's just start going through this. See
what I broke.
Oh, did I not finish debugging this?
Hang on.
Yeah, I didn't finish debugging this,
man. Huh? Okay. Oops.
I'd forgotten about that completely.
That was totally it.
I thought we would get NS, but
apparently we just don't.
Target pause minus agent pause. This is
a good
These OBS are
No, this just has scaling constants.
Doesn't do anything else. This shouldn't
mess with anything.
go see if I can find the commit from the
flag.
I hope for this person's sake that this
is not the thing. I don't think it is
because this look fine to me, but
it's happened before like this.
Yeah, I don't think this is a bug
either, but I'm just testing.
I think this is a new person. Let's make
sure that this is not a break.
It doesn't look like this is it.
It'd be pretty hard for this to be it.
like without the undeaf. Yeah.
But unless something else is literally
deaf, an R, a W or like nothing would
ever deaf. That
obviously you should still test your
code.
What the heck is wrong with this thing?
This should be This is like bizarre.
And try to see if I can do hover.
Go back to that with our new fixes.
It's just a stability thing. I doubt
it's just stability thing, but
Yeah. So, this does it still doesn't
work just to hover.
So, that doesn't really make any sense
to me why it would be
like how, right?
Wait, is this how I had the ops?
That look weird to me?
That looks weird to me.
I'm confused about this.
It's fine for this one.
Think it's fine for this, right?
the 88%.
We've had that problem before. That's
not new.
Can I Can they do the flag now?
If I do that
Yeah,
I mean there are a lot of things I need
to do with our tooling, man.
which seemed like that was just noise.
And the hover task like you can actually
just solve it sometimes I guess which is
weird.
Yeah, I thought that would be it. That's
so weird. And the training's not even
stable, which is even weirder.
That sort of consistent instability
usually means there's something very,
very wrong.
Thought there was just like a bad
commit. It was weird.
I'm honestly tempted at this point to
just go revert.
I don't know what the hell I did. This
is just what happens when I code when
I'm distracted. I guess I usually don't
have bugs like that. That's ridiculous.
So it looks like it's already broken
here, right?
We'll let this run, but yeah, it looks
like it's already broken here. We go
back even another commit.
Thanks for the poker shout out. Yeah, I
mean it's it's an awesome project, man.
The thing is, I think that literally if
we just have that environment running a
thousandx faster, like you would be able
to strip out most of the disgusting
reward hacks and stuff and like it would
get a lot more attention. It's just
straight up. It's hard to actually
optimize the thing properly and you sort
of just have to guess because you can't
run enough experiments. It's just like
the exact trap of classic RL work. It's
tough.
We'd like we would solve soabon really
quickly.
like the um
the tower climb game is kind of similar
Like if you just had if you just had um
like 16,000 parallel environments
instead of the 64 or 128 or however many
you have, it would be a very different
story.
Mazes. Yeah. And we solve that, right?
It's just straight up scale, man.
Slow M's not fun.
Okay, this doesn't really do it either,
I don't think.
slow MS.
Even if you want stuff to work on slow
MS, you don't do the research on slow
ends.
It's not how you make progress.
So there is a little bit of a sticking
point it looks like around here.
Oh, that's what that was. I never played
Starcraft.
Was never an RTS guy.
was around when Starcraft was uh super
popular, man. It's just uh wasn't into
RTS games.
Okay, I guess we have to e out this
policy now because
if this doesn't train, something's off.
This doesn't look like it trains, right?
Yeah, it doesn't train.
It's like a little better.
working on figuring out what's wrong
with this uh drone simulation.
Okay. So, they're like they're trying
but it's not even close, right?
No, this is it. This is the flag. It
works.
It works with eight
on the original task.
Okay.
Yeah. So 08 is actually correct then
See if this still works.
This commit
joining my uh master's program on data
science. Do you have any tips for me?
The uh I just published a really large
guide to ML programming reinforcement
learning. Okay. Published a ton of
educational material on uh X
yesterday. It's been doing quite well. I
would suggest reading that.
Okay. We're going to just back test
this. We're going to back test our way
into making this thing work.
You start again.
It helps. It helps out quite a bit.
Maybe I just had the scales wrong. I
don't know. There is definitely a bug of
some type, but maybe if this commit is
good, then it's not that bad.
I'm pretty much just going to figure out
what this is today.
and solve chess in a day.
I mean,
I don't know. You could probably write a
decent little chest engine in a day.
Okay, this still works. So, I'm
confused.
Yeah, this still works.
So, um
Okay, so the regression is apparently
somehow in between these two. That's
like a tiny commit, isn't it?
Or did I do something really weird?
Oh, no. I know what I can do.
I know what I can do. Okay,
hang on.
Dang. It didn't pick it up in the DI
sadly.
I can probably check the drone lib file
or whatever.
No, I can't.
Yeah, it's unfortunate then.
Oh, wait. Maybe maybe this is still
good.
Maybe this is still good.
This thing runs like more than 10,000
times real time. We trained a model to
play this game for 12,000 years on one
server in like three days.
This is not me playing. This is the
neural net playing in my browser.
You can see it knows how to equip items.
It knows how to kite enemies for the
most part.
It knows how to run around and explore.
It actually knows how to buy and sell
things a little bit on the market.
Uh, I actually think that I broke zoom
out for some reason. Bad. I don't know
how I did that, but I somehow I think
that the zoom out out of memory is the
uh the web version for some dumb reason.
You know, different levels of players.
Yeah, there's a leveling system here.
new beverage. Yeah, you can
you can do that as well.
I kind of don't want people pring like
random small features to neural MMO 3
bet.
What would you like in an improved MMO?
More depth, more interaction, so on. You
just have to program a bigger game is
all right.
Well, it's more so bet that like neural
MMO 3 is actually a really useful
benchmark for us and if we're going to
change it, we kind of want to make like
a big change. That's the new benchmark.
So, I I think that most likely the next
one will be when I get around to doing
neural MMO 4. So,
contributed beyond that level
and stuff.
I mean, that takes kind of like
everything I know to do that.
Okay. So I mean we know that I had I had
domain randomized
working
Could just be some SIM screw-ups because
I don't see anything else wrong with the
logic.
Yeah, if we probably just did something
dumb.
weird if out of bounds gets stuck at 7.
It shouldn't.
No, that's fine. Gamma's fine.
Weird. See it back.
It's interesting that this doesn't learn
to not o be
Oh, did my um hang on. Did my other fix
get tapped or no?
Ah, hang on. Maybe it's a combination of
these.
Yeah, that can't learn. We're going to
try this.
Try this one.
Yeah. Okay,
that's a big difference.
Now question is, does Perf actually fix
as well?
Or is it going to hover at the same
area of point like below seven? No, it
looks like it solves.
Well, this was a really dumb way to
spend an afternoon if this was the bug.
I guess it was a combination of two
things which makes sense that it was
layered like that.
Two very like simple oversightes though
ultimately.
Yeah, this solves
Okay. So, uh, the next thing is going to
be
I'm just going to make sure today really
all I want to do is make sure that we
have a decent starting point for this
stuff and then uh I can pick this up
know early next week
as soon as I know we have a decent
starting point.
We'll show a few cool demos though
before I finish uh with work today
because I think that this will look
pretty cool. I don't know how it's going
to do with the racing task cuz it's kind
of like a weird thing to add into the
same space, but um
we'll see how that goes.
That shouldn't be very hard.
Actually,
you know what we're going to do? We're
going to do
Yeah, that'll give it more fine grain
control because now it can see both
where the target is like the direction,
but it also when it gets close it can
see a more fine grained version of that.
The numbers getting to be too tiny.
[Music]
Interesting.
Okay. So, this does not train on all
tasks.
Let's assume that it's the racing task
breaking stuff
and let's see what this does.
So, at least initially, we'll see if
it's stable, but it does learn to not
OB.
And yeah, that looks like it's doing uh
that's reasonable stuff
again, at least initially. We might have
to reweep, we might have to do other
things, but
that was good. Perf
and I know 08 is the perf that you want.
So I can just do
this is fine.
and major. Welcome.
82 or whatever
like short order.
Try with randomizing the parameters a
little bit
What I'll do here is I'll try to uh I'm
going to try to finish stuff up early
today because I really got to go get
myself some exercise.
also have to answer some emails,
but I want to at least get us a very
cool drone demo today.
So, this is domain randomized multi
multitask training minus the racing
task. If this works, we'll just do
standalone racing task
and we'll figure out anything wrong with
that.
I know exactly what'll be wrong with
that to be fair. So, that's not going to
be a big deal.
Is the new physics stuff in there? Not
yet. It will be. I'll merge that in
quite soon. Don't worry.
This thing is still going a little bit.
That's crazy.
The physic the new physics I have not
looked at yet.
Oh, these guys are still alive. That's
awesome.
Hey, what if we put robots in pipes and
like shoot them through uh pipes to
deliver you stuff? It's funny.
It's like miniature hyperloop for
delivery robots.
pretty much that. Yeah, major. It's a
funny thing. I have no idea if it's
practical, but it's cool. All right, so
this still pretty well works. Um 2.8 8
is about what you'd expect for working
on this.
Next thing, racing task
Okay. So, where's the where are my rings
for this?
Oh yeah. No, this actually works. It's
not drawn. This is totally fine.
Motor lag. Did they in the new physics?
I will check that. That looks cool.
Or sounds cool at least.
How is these? I don't understand how
this just refuses to cash like literally
anything.
Okay, so this is the mess that's
happening here.
Lots of big drones crashing into each
other because they're too big,
I guess.
Let's try uh
a good thing I rendered that actually
So, I'm seeing if I make smaller drones,
right?
If that just solves it or not.
I mean, they're just too big, right?
Like these things.
I I guess that visually the rendering
isn't quite matched. They're not
actually quite as big as they're shown.
They're still pretty big. But uh
yeah,
heck, I think the collision checks
though are um
the collision checks don't depend on the
drone size except for the ones with the
rings.
So maybe this is not it.
Ah,
I see.
No, but if out of bounds,
we should still be getting negative out
of bounds, right?
No collision penalty. Yeah, this is
actually this should be very good.
Yeah, the rings are big enough. They
should be at least.
Because I have the same thing in drone
race, right?
Yeah, I have the same thing.
It works here.
All the ring checks are going to be
wrong.
3.2.
Yeah, I know. We're kind of slacking,
right?
Well, this is what I wanted to have. So,
uh,
why is that be going back up?
I'm just not stable.
This definitely does do something.
I have a question. Yeah, shoot.
Going to do add the domain randomization
back in.
see if that makes it better or worse.
Should make it harder but slightly more
stable. But we'll see if that's the
case.
Either way, I think this is the last
thing I want to do is train this and see
if it uh well, one more thing after
this. We'll say
One more thing after this.
[Music]
I know. Balancing the racing task with
the rest of them will be actually kind
of tricky.
Maybe we'll just check this policy and
call it.
It's going to be 13.5K by the end of the
day. That's just ridiculous.
When we name the word policy, is it
actually the step function?
No. Um policy is the neural network that
is computing actions. It is taking in
the observations and computing actions.
The step function is the implementation
of the environment logic that says based
on the actions given this is what should
happen in the environment. These are the
observations and this is the reward.
Okay. Well, we'll see what these guys
are doing. Possible they're not really
flying through the rings.
We will see.
It is more stable.
So that's cool to see. 3 mil SPS. No,
it's on the puffer box.
It's probably like 1 million. Like 1
point something million on a laptop.
the one guy in Discord. Yeah, that guy's
got a tough situation.
He's actually quite smart.
Well, that's not the issue cuz we can
always give a SSH to a box, right?
And you actually you'll probably end up
getting like you would actually probably
end up getting like 100,000 f FPS even
on a phone.
Yes, these guys aren't really doing
much, it seems.
Most likely there's just some bugs in
the race logic specifically.
Not a huge deal. We'll be able to fix
that.
But hey, at least we got the uh the flag
and things working again. So, pretty
much I think at this point we're like
we're pretty close to just having
everything working all in the same sim.
So, like we'll have the same policy, be
able to run through these hoops versus
do uh, you know, formations versus
whatever else. And with different size
drones as well, big drones, small
drones, all that.
That'll be quite good.
I think this will look really cool when
we're done.
All right. I do want to head out early
today because I want to go get some
exercise. I got some emails to answer
and I'm kind of just a bit tired from
all the uh the release stuff. Been going
through so many freaking messages and so
many meetings from uh the article.
So, for the folks tuning in, holy, we
have 3,700
uh unique views on X. You never know how
many of those are people scrolling by,
but that's like crazy. So for all the
people tuning in, thank you very much.
This is all open source.
So if you're interested in what you see
here, I stream all my dev usually Monday
through Saturday.
You want to help me out for free, start
the repository right here.
If you want to get involved with
development, join the Discord. We have
lots of people in here. I'll help you
get started in addition to the articles.
And of course, you can follow me on X
for more content.